it's that time once again time to round
up all of netflix's significant comings
and goings for the month of august 2020.
plenty of new sci-fi action drama and
comedy features are on tap to break up
the boredom during this
the summer of the well-worn couch
netflix is bringing some huge tentpole
films into the fold in august 2020.
first and foremost jurassic park the
lost world jurassic park
and jurassic park 3 will all be hitting
the streamer in august
so if it's been a while since you've
taken in those classics you're in luck
also ocean's 12 and ocean's 13 will be
making appearances
ocean's 11 has been available on netflix
us for some time now but subscribers
outside the states can stream it in
august as well
also hitting the streamer in august 2020
are the first two daniel craig eric
james bond flicks casino royale and
quantum of solace
although not until the last day of the
month among the other exciting
selections you'll want to check out
the heath ledger starring medieval romp
a night's tale the first person action
or hardcore henry
george miller's original 1979 film mad
max and the classic heartstring tugger
the never ending story in its sequel
netflix will also be unleashing its
original action flicks project power and
the sleepover during the month of august
unfortunately horror fans don't have a
ton of new stuff to look forward to on
netflix in august 2020 with only three
new freight flicks hitting the streamer
first up is what keeps you alive in
which married couple jackie and jewels
head off to a remote cabin in the woods
to celebrate their first anniversary
when a mysterious friend shows up emily
quickly begins to suspect that all is
not as it appears
of course she couldn't be more right and
a romantic getaway suddenly takes a
potentially deadly turn
next we have we summon the darkness
which stars alexandria d'addario as a
young heavy metal fan in the 80s on her
way to a concert with two friends
when the trio meet up with three boys
looking for a good time it's revealed
that the girls have a much different
type of good time in mind
one that involves ritualistic murder
finally one br which presumably stands
for one bedroom following a new arrival
in los angeles who lucks into the
apartment of her dreams
unfortunately it turns out that her
ultra friendly helpful neighbors have
some sinister ulterior motives turning
her dream apartment into a nightmare
screwball comedies coming to netflix on
august 2020 include films like rowan
atkinson's 2003 james bond spoof johnny
english
the 2002 adam sandler and wynonna ryder
star mr deeds and scary movie 5
the final entry in one of the goofiest
series of all time among the more
highbrow comedic offerings for august is
being john malkovich
the first collaboration between director
spike jones and screenwriter charlie
kaufman
it stars john cusack is a man who
discovers a portal inside the mind of
the titular actor who also stars in the
film
mid-month will bring a safety not
guarantee a time travel rom-com star in
aubrey plaza and jake johnson
and directed by colin trevorrow also
coming in august 2020 is the netflix
original workit
a high energy dance film produced by the
great songstress alicia keys
in august 2020 make sure to check out
michelle gaundry's mind-bending film
eternal sunshine of the spotless mind
starring kate winslet and jim carrey
it drops on august 1st along with the
diane lane and richard gere romance
knights and rodonti and the horse racing
flick seabiscuit
later in the month you can hear the
people singing in tom hooper's 2012
version of les miserables featuring hugh
jackman and anne hathaway
if you're in the mood for something a
little more contemporary check out the
argentinian crime drama criminais de
familia which centers on a mother
attempting to keep her son out of prison
after he's accused of the attempted
murder of his ex-wife
we hope you're ready to laugh and learn
because netflix is releasing a bevy of
documentaries and original stand-up
specials in august 2020.
you definitely won't want to miss the
first one-hour netflix special from
comedian and saturday night live writer
sam jay
titled sam j three in the morning which
includes jay's thoughts on traveling
with her girlfriend
she was packing i was packing but then
she started packing a third bag
and that really confused me because she
only has two arms august 2nd sees the
release of connected a new docu-series
exploring the often unseen ways in which
everything in our world is related
that's followed by an in-depth look at
the current state of america's
immigration system and the limited
docu-series immigration nation which
drops august 3rd
later in the month make sure to keep
your eyes peeled for unwell an expose on
the wellness industry
also coming in august is high score a
docu-series that takes a look at the
early days of video games
netflix's tv schedule for august 2020 is
stacked with bingeable shows and as
usual the streamers got a little
something for everyone
if you're a fan of reality shows keep an
eye out for new seasons of nailed it
mexico
selling sunset rust valley restores and
glow up
or if you're a fan of anime inspired
sci-fi cartoons all four seasons of
nickelodeon's the legend of korra are
arriving on august 14th
lovers of international tv will enjoy
dystopian sci-fi thrillers the rain and
3 percent from denmark and brazil
both of which are getting new seasons in
august 2020. viewers can also catch up
on the latest antics of an oddball
schoolteacher when the danish comedy
rita launches its fifth season on august
15th
the same day as the release of season
two of the south korean crime thriller
stranger
on august 21st the fifth season of
lucifer drops the first half of its
episodes
additionally starting on august 28th
nostalgia addicts can catch up on the
first two seasons of the karate kids
spin off cobra kai
ahead of the announced third season for
all the fantastic additions netflix is
making in august 2020 the streamer is
also losing quite a few tv shows and
movies from its lineup
if you're a fan of gritty teen dramedies
don't wait a second longer to binge the
seminal british series skins before it
leaves netflix on august 1st
on august 3rd we'll also be losing two
seasons of paranormal survivor
the docu-series about folks who have
experienced the supernatural and lived
to tell their tales
on august 31st 90s classics like
clueless jerry maguire
groundhog day and candyman are all
dropping off the menu
along with the karate kid the karate kid
part 2 and the karate kid part 3.
will smith and martin lawrence's action
film bad boys and its sequel bad boys 2
are both signing off as well other
notable departures include the beloved
80s comedy tootsie the early 2000s
rom-com's failure to launch and he's
just not that into you
the russell brand and jonah hill
starring flick get him to the greek and
the political thriller be for vendetta
thankfully there is still plenty of time
to squeeze these movies and shows in
before they say goodbye at the end of
august 2020.
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you